so the Trump tax documents are starting
to filter out and it's instantly
terrible for Donald Trump instantly
evidence of financial fraud that we
believed for years was exactly what tax
documents would reveal now this is not
Donald Trump's tax returns I know that
there are people who maybe misunderstood
the headlines around this this is not
Trump's tax returns
ProPublica has obtained some Donald
Trump tax documents and they show
exactly what we've predicted for a long
time which is that Donald Trump is
playing very fast and loose with the
value of assets and profitability that
he claims depending on whether he's
trying to impress a lender or avoid
taxation specifically Pro Publica has
documents that relate to they relate to
I believe it's for manhattan buildings
that donald trump owns and they obtained
these documents through Freedom of
Information Act requests and the
documents were provided because these
documents were made public because Trump
appealed his property tax bill for the
buildings in question every year for in
some cases nine years in a row and so
what Pro Publica was able to do very
solid investigation was take the tax
records and compare them with loan
records that Donald Trump's lender
ladder capital made public when they
sold the debt but this isn't just
generally saying to a lender oh my
buildings worth 50 million and then
saying to the IRS the building's only
worth 25 million that is something I'm
sure Donald Trump is doing and Michael
Cohen told us that that's what Donald
Trump is doing but this is actually more
Donald Trump is actually lying about how
much rent the buildings are taking in
which is a much more calculated and
specific type of lie some might call it
fraud and in fact the number of real
estate professionals are calling it
exactly that so here's one example
Donald Trump told his lender that the
buildings earn twice as much rent that
one building earns twice as much rent as
what he told tax authorities in the same
year in 2017
okay both can't be
those are lies this is financial fraud
another example
Trump's building at 40 Wall Street I
would walk by this building every day
because our David Pakman show studios in
New York City were like a block from
Trump's building at 40 Wall Street I'd
walk by it every day Trump told a lender
that 40 Wall Street went from being 59%
leased to 95% leased in a period of a
few years but then around the same time
that he was telling the lender it was 59
percent leased he told tax officials
that the building was 81 percent leased
now we're still trying to figure out
what the advantage to doing that is
there may be disincentives to have empty
buildings although I need to research a
little more about New York City tenant
landlord law and restrictions and and
provisions but whatever the impetus was
it doesn't make sense and that's what's
immediately revealed by these documents
sometimes the exact motivation for the
discrepancies is not completely clear
does he want a stronger position to
receive money from a lender does he want
to minimize tax liability from the from
the government the state government of
New York but in other cases it's not
totally clear what the impetus is for
each lie but ProPublica went with
everything that they uncovered to a
dozen real estate professionals and the
real estate professionals were basically
unanimous in their assessment number one
there is no clear explanation for this
but number two these discrepancies are
and this is a quote versions of fraud
which would not be a surprise to anybody
who's been following this now this type
of fraud can lead to criminal charges
it's very unlikely that it will because
nothing has been sticking to Donald
Trump but note that Trump's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen and
Trump's former campaign chairman Paul
Manafort are in prison in part for
falsifying tax and bank records some of
which relate to real estate all in the
service of at least when it comes to
Michael Cohen Donald Trump so this is
very serious stuff the big picture the
big picture is that this is called
double bookkeeping
fraudsters typically do this they
maintain one set of books that's the set
you show certain entities and there's
another set of books that is either your
private set of books or the one that you
keep on hand to show other regulatory
entities depending on what is most
advantageous at the time really solid
investigation by Pro Publica and under
that I mean look you look at just a few
buildings and it's immediately clear
that something isn't right this is just
for buildings that they looked at
imagine if we were able to actually get
Donald Trump's tax returns what might be
in there his voters might not care sure
but it would be an absolute treasure
trove it's almost like Trump knows that
his tax returns going public would be
absolutely terrible for him and possibly
implicate him in crimes so he's going
completely out of his way to do
everything he can to prevent their
release exactly as we've been saying for
years back all the way since before he
even started the general election
debates against Hillary Clinton in the
2016 campaign will we ever see the tax
returns I don't know I don't know but I
hope that we do there is a fascinating
audio recording that has been leaked in
which a prominent Republican is caught
saying that Donald Trump is quote
killing us
meaning killing not even necessarily
Republicans but even some trumpian
Republicans in important local races and
this is a riveting peek behind the
curtain in the chaos of the Republican
Party under Donald Trump the Texas
Republican House Speaker Dennis Bonin is
on a radio on an audio recording rather
asking for help asking members of his
own Republican Party in 2020 he's on
recording calling a female lawmaker vile
and saying that Donald Trump is quote
killing us now Democrats have filed a
lawsuit that accuses Bannen of breaking
campaign finance laws who isn't breaking
campaign finance laws these days right
and there is also a state probe into
allegations of corruption this meeting
was secretly recorded by the CEO of a
group called empower Texans with
is a far-right group whose CEO Michael
Quinn Sullivan said the reason I
recorded it was to protect myself which
is also a very interesting detail in all
of this and this is all happening
because Republicans are at risk of
losing control of the Texas House as you
probably know if you follow politics
Texas is a historically conservative
state although there have been shades of
purple more and more recently
particularly in some Eric areas but
regardless Republicans have controlled
the Texas House for almost two decades
and now Republicans are in a position
where they could lose control of the
house if they lose nine seats to
Democrats in 2020 many Republicans are
panicking and Bannen is blaming Donald
Trump he says on the recording with all
due respect to Trump who I love he's
killing us in urban suburban districts
now this warrants some thought is it
true that Donald Trump is killing them
the answer is very regional it may well
be that in Texas in urban and suburban
districts Trump is hurting the brand of
Republicans that Bannen is a part of in
some parts of the country it's not that
clear although increasingly including in
North Carolina which will we've already
dealt with on today's show Trump is
certainly not helping ultimately if
Trump destroys the Republican Party as
we know it or at least seriously hurts
it for a decade it is their fault they
voted for him they are choosing this
rope to hang themselves with if
ultimately it is what they hang
themselves with but it's up to us to
make it happen and I've talked about
that already there's another thing to
point out dennis Bannen and the
contingent in Texas that is trying to
get other Republicans removed from
office this is an extreme group of
Republicans Dennis Bannen
loves Trump but he claims to recognize
that Donald Trump is hurting them what
Dennis Bannen and his cronies are trying
to do is remove what are some of the
more moderate Texas Republicans and
replace them with unhinged trumpian
lunatics he merely recognizes or at
least believes that Donald Trump is
hurting their cause to do that
we should not mistake this for Bannen
being the moderate Bannen is an absolute
maniac and in the end we get to the same
place as nationally on this issue if we
vote we can do good things if we vote
nationally in November of 2020 we can
remove Trump we have the numbers it's a
question of how many of those numbers
will turn up at the ballot box
if Texan Democrats vote they can
potentially flip Texas blue which would
be an accomplishment of stunning
historic proportions if we don't vote if
they if you Texas Democrats don't vote
then everything stays the same or
potentially gets even worse and in the
end I mean it's like you know when you
have an election with so many different
factors Russian meddling problems with
voting machines social media campaigns
and echo chambers right-wing media
perpetuating the feedback loops through
algorithmic echo chambers all of the
stuff we've talked about it is really
you know Hillary not going to Wisconsin
in the last days of the race when you
have elections that hinge on under a
hundred thousand votes in three states
it's very hard to say this is the one
thing that decided the results because
there are so many other things that
could have changed them the one part
that is completely clear is that if
voter turnout wasn't 50% if the left
just got out and voted in droves the
answer is none of those little things
matter none of those medium-sized things
matter because we just have the numbers
now of course the opposite is true if we
don't vote and the right is able to
invigorate their base and get out and
vote we don't stand a chance and that's
why ultimately you can point to any
point to blame whatever you want for
2016 in a pragmatic sense
Hillary not campaigning correctly
towards the end Russian meddling fear of
losing status racism blame anything you
want but know that we can over we we can
outdo the impact of all of those
elements by increasing voter turnout
which sounds like it should be easy to
do and it never quite works
unfortunately all right so I joked that
this would happen last week on Twitter
and it's happening Donald Trump now has
said that he does not know if Rudy
Giuliani is his lawyer of course Rudy
Giuliani now under criminal federal
investigation two of Rudy Giuliani's
associates have been arrested trying to
leave the country on one-way plane
tickets I tweeted last week after Olivia
Newton si wrote that Trump says he
hasn't spoken to Rudy but Rudy tells me
he spoke to Trump yesterday Trump says
he doesn't know if Rudy is his attorney
Rudy tells me he is and he has no reason
to think he's not I tweeted Rudy who is
coming in 3 2 1 now we're not yet at
Donald Trump saying Rudy Giuliani yeah I
don't really know who that is but we are
at Rudy my attorney oh I don't know
about that here's video Donald Trump
asked is Rudy Giuliani your lawyer
check out Donald Trump's answer well I
don't know I haven't spoken to Rudy I
spoke to him yesterday briefly
he's a very good attorney and he has
been my attorney I haven't spoken to him
I spoke to him yesterday well so you
have spoken to him I guess you mean you
haven't spoken to him in the last few
hours but you spoke to him yesterday
he's a good attorney I don't know if
he's my attorney Rudy Giuliani was asked
are you still Donald Trump's attorney
and he said that he is at least at the
most recent time I am still his lawyer
until he tells me I'm not I spoke to him
yesterday and I have no reason to
believe I'm not he said to New York
magazines Olivia newts
Rudy was also asked whether he thinks
Trump is going to throw him under the
bus and he said he doesn't think so
which does not it's like when Trump says
he is full confidence in you and 24
hours later you've been forced to resign
this is exactly what Trump did when
Michael Cohen who's now in prison when
Michael Cohen his former personal
attorney was starting to get into
trouble Michael Cohen oh I don't know he
was my attorney at one point he's not
the best guy and you know he was asking
me for all this stuff that I didn't give
him Trump after that video though that
I played did tweet nice things about
Rudy but this is the start of the
distancing from Rudy Giuliani we've seen
it done before and Trump is doing it
again coffee boy
Rudy Giuliani he was barely involved
with anything I did when you start
ghosting your lawyer your prominent
famous on TV every day lawyer because
he's under criminal investigation and
two of his associates have been arrested
and charged that's not good and there's
an important thing to understand here
and this may become relevant actually
depending on where impeachment goes
depending on where the criminal
investigation into Rudy Giuliani goes
what's important to understand is that
as his personal attorney it's not clear
that Rudy Giuliani is doing legal work
per se for Trump in the sense that Rudy
is a lawyer and calling him Trump's
lawyer is useful for attorney-client
privilege but in the strictest sense
other lawyers are doing Trump's actual
legal work the filings and the work you
would typically associate with an
attorney Rudy Giuliani is basically
doing influence-peddling meetings all
over the world and television
appearances but the bulk of the legal
work is not being done by really Rudy
Rudy Giuliani if any at all it's
becoming a bad comedy does anybody
believe that someone in Donald Trump's
position possibly facing charges of all
kinds facing impeachment doesn't know
who his lawyer is that doesn't seem like
something that is very reasonable even
considering that this is Donald Trump
bizarre times that we are living in and
who knows if a week from now Rudy
Giuliani will be under indictment it's
anyone's guess this may be the last we
hear of the Rudy investigation or the
guy may be indicted next week either
would be equally surprising or
unsurprising to me at this point in time
let me know what you think Rudy's future
is legally and also when it comes to his
role with Donald Trump all right it has
not been a good few weeks for Donald
Trump and yesterday he had an absolute
tantrum when meeting with Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi as well as other
leaders
it has devolved to such a point that
concerns about Donald Trump's mental
health which I've been raising for more
than a year are becoming front and
center because the behavior is so on the
fringes Trump yesterday met with House
leadership because Congress passed a
bipartisan rebuke of Donald Trump's
decision to pull troops from northern
Syria
so Trump bring Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi to the White House some of
his generals are there other advisers
and after the meeting it starts to
become clear that something really odd
went down Chuck Schumer saying that
Trump turned the meeting into a diatribe
that included just attacking Nancy
Pelosi personally that many in the room
say it was completely insulting so it
was clear something weird happened and
then this picture was released from the
meeting in which Donald Trump's side of
the table looks visibly pained as Nancy
Pelosi is standing and pointing and
appearing to lecture Donald Trump the
way you might lecture an eight-year-old
that just isn't behaving and Trump has
this indignant look on his face but as
usual Trump put the picture out to make
Nancy Pelosi seem on hinge this is the
the pattern Trump puts out the truncated
version of the Ukraine phone call
thinking it vindicates him and it's
incriminating Trump puts out the letter
he wrote to President Erdogan thinking
it makes him look strong and it makes
him look like an absolute lunatic and
here Donald Trump puts out this picture
thinking it makes him look good but when
you look at the or Pelosi unhinged but
when you look at the picture if you look
at the other people in the room it is
abundantly clear that Trump is the one
behaving oddly here once again like the
petulant child and if you look at a
closer shot of the advisors that are
sitting to Donald Trump's right they
have that pained unfortunate grimace on
their faces looking down at the table in
embarrassment as Nancy Pelosi scolds
Trump as if he's a little kid and of
course he often acts like one so then
hours go by it becomes clear that Donald
Trump appears to have cracked during
this meeting and Nancy Pelosi actually
says now I'm concern
learned about Trump's health the
implication of course being mental
health because this was a serious
meltdown it's really sad about it is I
prayed for the president all the time
and I tell him that I pray for his
safety and about his family think now we
have to pray for his health because this
was a very serious meltdown on the part
of the president the behavior is erratic
childish and it's dangerous all at once
simultaneously and then of course after
the meeting Donald Trump making no sense
totally dissociating from the reality of
the situation talking about how they're
dealing with a region that has lots of
sand Syria may have some help with
Russia and that's fine it's a lot of
sand they've got a lot of sand over
there so there's a lot of said that they
can play with listen the mental health
red alert if not now when
I mean seriously if this is not enough
for us to say and I don't mean us like
just the people on the Left who have
been following Trump's deterioration I
mean the American public if this is not
enough for us to say something is wrong
with this man now this doesn't excuse
his lack of morality and ethics this
doesn't excuse his terrible misguided
ignorant political views but on top of
it there is obviously something going on
either cognitively and/or with substance
abuse here that he cannot put together a
sensible take on anything he cannot
speak reasonably to anyone whether it's
the Turkish president in that unhinged
letter that he wrote or to Nancy Pelosi
at the White House and then in the
background every single one of these
missteps and bizarre things that Trump
does is not merely entertainment and
casual concern this is a national
security risk and we are seeing that
immediately within hours after his
decision to pull troops from northern
Syria something has to be done the
quickest path may still be removal by
voting him out in November of 2020 but
are we ready to have the adult
conversation that even Republicans need
to concede that something is very wrong
at a fundamental level I don't know I
don't know that they're ready to make
that acknowledgement make sure you're
following me on Instagram at David
Hockman and while you're there follow
the show on instagram at david pakman
show quick break right back after this
we've been talking about this for years
Fox News is a completely toxic extremist
right wing echo chamber mostly
sympathetic to President Donald Trump
but occasionally not but every once in a
while one of their anchors Shepard Smith
would tell the truth he would say what
Donald Trump says in this video what
Donald Trump said in this press
conference is not true he would say what
the Trump administration is telling you
is without evidence and we knew that
Shep was out of place this entire time
but we also recognized it might have
been useful to Fox News to have him
there to provide ideological cover to
allow themselves to say marginally more
credibly we're fair and balanced there
is diversity of opinion on our network
and recently it started getting very
publicly ugly
for example Shep Smith a week or two ago
interviewed Fox legal analyst Andrew
Napolitano at a former judge and
Napolitano said listen
Trump's actions with Ukraine are both
impeachable and potentially criminal
fellow Fox News hosts Tucker Carlson
came in and attacked the judge and then
Shep and Tucker got into a public
argument that had to be mediated by Fox
News higher-ups telling Shep Smith
you've got to cut it out that was a big
signal that things were not looking good
for Shep Smith and Shep Smith has now
quit Fox News here's a little bit of him
signing off on his last broadcast I've
worked with the most talented dedicated
and focused professionals I've ever
known they sacrifice endlessly and
tirelessly to get the news exactly right
and I am so proud of them and I'm
honored to have anchored their work each
day I'll miss them and our time together
greatly and deeply so recently I asked
the company to allow me to leave Fox
News after requesting that I stay they
obliged under our agreement I won't be
reporting elsewhere at least in the near
future but I will be able to see more of
gee
and Lucia and our friends and family
then we'll see what comes along this is
my last newscast here thank you for
watching today and over the decades as I
travel to many of your communities and
anchored this program Studio B and Fox
report plus endless marathon hours of
breaking news it's been an honor
so as Shep says they're contractually
he's not allowed to pop up on CNN or
MSNBC or ABC News for some time who
knows what he'll be doing financially
he's just fine he doesn't have to work
probably ever again if he doesn't want
to but let's go through this
sequentially first of all Shep says it
was voluntary I believe that strictly
speaking it was voluntary but it was
voluntary in a context where his bosses
had recently come to him and said do not
go after Tucker Carlson again it was
happening as president Trump was
increasingly attacking Shepard Smith it
was coming in this context of increased
tension with the broader network because
of his criticisms of Donald Trump and
it's pretty clear that other Fox hosts
were not expecting this based on what
they said on air there was speculation
that Shep was pushed out by Trump's
attorney General William bar now you
might say William bar what on earth does
William bar have to do with this well it
turns out that the day before Shep's
resignation William bar met with a Fox
News owner News Corporation owner a
Rupert Murdoch it is sketchy but there
is no evidence right now that the
meeting was directly related to Shep
Smith so then we get to is this good or
bad
because all along I've been saying on
the one hand Shep telling the truth
every once in a while might pierce the
echo-chamber filter bubble of the Fox
audience and that's a good thing but on
the other hand having Shep at Fox News
as I mentioned already gives them some
plausible deniability about being
anything other than tools of the
American right wing
I think in the net the benefits of Shep
at Fox did not outweigh the ideological
cover that he was providing to them and
especially after becoming a target of
Donald Trump I I understand his decision
to do
this whenever he is allowed
contractually to get back on the air
somewhere else he is going to be in a
great position to advance his career not
that that's my primary concern I'm
guessing he's not going to make as
boneheaded decisions as the ones that
megyn kelly made when she left Fox News
which basically imploded her career that
remains to be seen but there are still
lots of Fox viewers who see this as an
unabashed victory they hated Shep they
would anytime he told the truth start
making homophobic comments about Shep as
if his sexual orientation has anything
to do with whether he's telling us the
truth or not they see him leaving as a
victory and in a sense for them it may
be because the fox viewers that are
beyond reach the ones that are beyond
the hope of being pulled back into
considering the reality of the facts on
the ground they saw Shep as a threat
quite frankly and for them Shep leaving
is indeed a victory so not surprising
probably in the net something that is
not going to have any kind of real
impact on the 2020 election or on Donald
Trump but not a surprising thing as
we've been following for a couple of
years now and we will see where Shep
lands and we will see interestingly also
will there be any you know Trump has
also been going after Chris Wallace who
less frequently than Shep but every once
in a while will insert some truth into
his broadcasts or his challenging
questions the Trump officials is Chris
Wallace the next target if you look at
Trump's Twitter over the last couple of
days you see that the answer is probably
yes Chris Wallace is the next target all
right let's start today with the
Democratic presidential debate number
four which took place last night on CNN
a roughly three-hour affair I did stream
commentary for about the first 45
minutes of it before
CNN shut it down Sam Cedars stream
getting shut down about 90 minutes in or
so according to the tweets that I got
turns out CNN is much more aggressive
than anybody else when it comes to
preventing any commentary streams about
their debates but we have time today to
talk about
and in general one would expect that
over time you will have fewer
participants in primary debates although
the Democratic debates so far sort of
going in the opposite direction after
getting down from twenty to ten or
eleven we were back up to twelve
participants yesterday and it was a
complete and total mess which is one of
the things that I'll talk about I
decided I'm not going to play any clips
from the debate in this segment two
reasons really one I want to have more
time for commentary in a three hour
debate you know there weren't really
these short moments that lend themselves
to highlights per se and in any case
there are a whole bunch of you know 15
20 minute highlight videos online and
CNN is being so punitive when it comes
to copyright we will just be doing my
thoughts on it and you know check out
the clips later widely available online
so let's talk about that first thing I
mentioned once again debates with 12
people on the stage aren't good that was
again confirmed last night and I don't
want to be labor this but yet again as
if we didn't know you don't really get a
chance for much depth when you have 12
people on stage unless you just
straight-up ignore some of them for long
periods of time which actually did also
happen yesterday which is logical in a
sense in that you know there's a big
conversation right now on health care
for example between the Bernie Warren
view and the Biden view which is
different but then also within Bernie
Warren because their positions are also
different and that was a topic we'll
talk about and for a while everybody
else was just sort of ignored so it's
like I get why they're doing that but at
the same time we should just have fewer
people on the stage that's what would
really make the most sense now important
going in especially as we get this far
into the primary where the positions of
the candidates are really mostly known
they may not be known to every voter but
there aren't really secrets where
candidates have not yet told us their
positions on certain issues it's
important to understand the context is
one where debates rarely move polling in
any significant way and when they do
it's often not permanent if it's up
unless you really mess up in which case
you could do permanent damage to
yourself and that's been the theme for
the first three debates example first
debate the big kill shot that got a ton
of attention and play the next day was
Kamala Harris going after Joe Biden that
was either the first or second debate
it got her a spike in the polling
immediately but then that eroded over
the 10 to 14 days that followed and
Kamala Harris went right back to where
she was so the positive you know gotcha
moments only seem to work in the short
term with debates and then things
regularize another example Joe Biden Joe
Biden has had terrible debates mostly
his first and second the third one he
was rather the first and third were not
very good in the second one he actually
did okay because he was just attacked
even in irrational ways that made him
look like a martyr quite frankly and he
ended up doing okay in that debate Joe
Biden has generally performed poorly and
he has had a permanent decline in the
polls
so again case in point the debates tend
not to permanently move polling very
much unless you do poorly so what I was
interested in watching was going to be
number one does Bernie Sanders go after
Elizabeth Warren we talked about the
mathematical complexities of how does
Bernie get back into the running for
being in first place he's now pretty
significantly behind both Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden and the
complexities mathematically are that the
people that Bernie could attack both
Biden and Warren their supporters prefer
in other words Biden supporters prefer
Warren over Bernie and Warren supporters
prefer Biden over Bernie so by attacking
them it's not clear that Bernie actually
helps himself so this was a question
does Bernie go after Warren and we'll
talk about that I tweeted yesterday that
he likely wouldn't I said that the more
likely scenario was that Bernie would
draw some mild distinctions from Warren
but that nothing would really change and
this is basically how it went and we'll
get more into that momentarily another
element I was watching for does Joe
Biden
seem more energized not an analysis of
his policy but does he seem this
shrunken slowed-down Biden or does he
seem more energized he was more
energized to some degree last night
compared to his just terrible prior
performances unclear that it will change
very much Elizabeth Warren who now has
almost Co frontrunner status with Biden
was definitely more of a target a number
of people on stage going after her the
focus of more attacks and disagreements
which we'll get to she weathered some of
them okay less well with others
including questions around health care
and I'll get to that we also wanted to
pay attention to how do other candidates
go after or not go after Biden on the
hunter Biden stuff right even if you
don't believe the conspiracy theory that
is being parodied by Trump and the
people around him regarding Joe Biden
and Ukraine and that's all it is a
conspiracy theory without evidence you
can still be critical of that $50,000 a
month Consulting position that hunter
Biden had with the Ukrainian gas company
and there was a question as to how would
the other candidates go after Biden for
that the answer was not that much there
really wasn't that much discussion about
it Biden did get asked about it his
response was pretty pathetically
wishy-washy and muddled and uninspiring
basically changing the subject and not
really addressing it and that was mostly
that foreign policy foreign policy has
been a weak point not just in the
debates but it's a weak point for many
of the candidates who don't really
demonstrate I don't want to say they
don't have the knowledge because they
may have it somewhere in there but
they've not demonstrated deep knowledge
on foreign policy does anyone actually
propose prescriptions on foreign policy
instead of just criticizing Trump there
wasn't that much the most discussed
foreign policy topic yesterday was Syria
and the Kurds understandably almost
everybody on the stage was against the
haphazard withdrawal or at least the way
that Trump did it they were opposed to
tulsi gabbard sort of waffled on it we
know that this is her position she took
a position that the entire problem is
not Trump with
drawing its regime-change wars and
endless wars which is a major problem
with American foreign policy but its
myopic and simplistic when it comes to
this particular issue as well but that's
been her talking point on most foreign
policy issues she's staked that out
there's a slice of the left that likes
it and right now it's gotten her 0.8
percent support from Democratic primary
voters but other than that either
disagreement with the way that
withdrawal was done or with the
withdrawal period the other candidates
did take the opportunity to distance
themselves from Tulsi gabbard's position
Pete Buddha judge for example said that
she's just straight-up wrong about it
but it was a relatively small part of
the debate the first question they made
the right decision because there were 12
people on stage to skip opening
statements which I loved they made the
wrong decision to open the debate with a
question about what do you think about
impeachment which was a complete waste
of time basically everybody's for
impeachment Tulsi Gabbard not really for
it
Pete Buddha judge a little worried about
what the consequences may be but we knew
that nothing useful was learned from
that question it took up about twenty
minutes or more it provided an
opportunity for some of the candidates
to grandstand and it was really really
lame speaking of lame and cringe-worthy
billionaire Tom Steyer who effectively
bought his way into the debate was
totally cringe worthy his first
opportunity to speak he tried he went
directly to an applause line where the
audience of course has been told
basically to shut the eff up and not
make noise and very few people reacted
and it was just downhill from there for
Tom Steyer contributing noting his
presence was totally superfluous in
every way and unfortunately I believe
he's qualified for the fifth debate
Elizabeth Warren had a particularly weak
moment last night and it was when she
was answering the question will taxes go
up under your health care plan I don't
want to repeat myself again and again
and again but I've already addressed
many times a variety of ways in which
candidates could answer this question
and she unfortunately repeated some of
the same talking points multiple
including some version of I will not
sign a bill into law that doesn't lower
costs for middle-class families sort of
a strange double negative and really the
answer is listen we know what the answer
is you have total health care costs
taxes are a component of a single-payer
plan but in total costs will go down
Bernie actually handled this pretty well
yesterday Bernie has also totally missed
the mark on this question Bernie said in
clear terms total costs will go down you
get rid of co-pays you get rid of
premiums you get rid of coinsurance all
of that stuff you add a payroll tax it
will be mostly it will be
disproportionately increased for
corporations and for the rich mostly
everybody will pay a little bit but your
total costs will go down it's the truth
and it's a perfectly reasonable way to
do it because people's costs aren't zero
now now there's some conflict about the
math of that statement in terms of some
of the claims Bernie has made and that's
okay we're figuring it out but in the
end
Bernie messaged that way better last
night and Elizabeth Warren fell short
and she was vulnerable as a result of it
multiple candidates saying why can't you
just answer the question not her best
moment last night in what was overall a
pretty good performance Andrew yang's
Andrew Yang's performance Andrew Yang's
followers have been tweeting to me
saying Andrew yang destroyed it he's
about to break into the top three now I
didn't really see it that way Andrew
yang did go after Elizabeth Warren for
not adopting his thousand dollar-a-month
universal basic income proposal she said
well I want to increase Social Security
payments it was a nice attempt by Andrew
yang to get some face time with the
presumptive ko front-runner at this
point Elizabeth Warren I don't think
it's gonna make much of an impression or
impact polling Bernie's health came up
of course having a heart attack
couple of weeks ago Bernie handled it as
well as you can while standing up on a
stage and claiming that you're fine his
voice and his energy seemed basically
back to normal so that was
good I don't think he did any damage to
himself when that topic came up Kamala
Harris brought another one of her gotcha
attempts when she asked Elizabeth Warren
will you join me in calling for Trump to
be banned on Twitter and Warren said no
and it was sort of an anticlimactic
gotcha moment Harris tried to be shocked
no you won't but it was a pretty weak
gotcha
attempt there's way bigger fish to fry
and Kamala Harris has effectively done
unless like in the next month she can
double her support from you know 5% to
10% the last question of the night was
also a throwaway tell us about a
surprising friendship that you have with
someone real waste of time and I know
some people in my audience will say no
no here's why that was actually an
interesting question it was a waste of
time I want to hear about policy overall
takeaways another dog and pony show
component a big part of it
relatively few new policy details were
discussed I don't expect any big changes
in polling except Bernie looking
generally healthy might help him recover
a little bit of what he's lost in the
last couple of weeks
Biden's seeming slightly higher energy
maybe will help him recover a little bit
as well no one really failed but the
people that are polling you know Z one
to two percent I don't see that they're
going to be doing any better as a result
of this debate Bernie did pretty well
with the questions he was given Biden
again given that Biden is this sort of
slowed down Biden he did pretty well
given the questions he was given
although he fumbled when he was asked
about the hunter Biden thing obviously
Biden supporters won't like the content
of what Bernie said Bernie supporters
won't like the content of what Biden
said but they both did well enough to
not do damage the candidates I thought
overall sounded more rehearsed and less
genuine than in Prior debates as if
they're now being guided more by polling
and calculated politics
sadly although very often that's where
it gets to at this point in the race
bottom line is that we can't keep having
12 people on the stage it's just
horrible I mean what does amy klobuchar
think about impeachment
what does Julian Castro think about
Syria well what what why is tulsi
gabbard not fully behind impeachment I
mean it's like who cares right they have
no chance and I want to get into depth
with the people that do have a shot a
fifth debate is on November 20th the new
qualification requirements are 3% in
four or more approved polls or 5% in two
or more early primary state polls and
165,000 donations now as of right now we
are like a full month out from that next
debate there are already eight people
qualified for that debate so we may end
up again with 10 people just not
conducive to good conversation right now
the people qualified for debate number
five are Biden Sanders Warren Harris
Budaj Tom Styer again Andrew Yang and
Cory Booker so we already are going to
have eight people on stage last thing I
continue to be generally concerned about
the idolatry of politicians it's not
just Tulsi and yang there are you know
Bernie idolaters Warren idolaters from
the tweets that I'm getting when I asked
for feedback about debates or polling or
whatever on Twitter people just as a few
civ about some of these candidates as if
these are saviors or near deities and my
position is politicians just aren't the
best period these aren't I would argue
even the types of people that we should
be idolizing and without commenting on
any specific politicians I would just
want to see sort of more measured
analyses than the gushing praise of
pseudo deities that I'm seeing on
Twitter about certain candidates that's
just me I just don't see politicians in
the same light maybe it's because I do
this show and I've met a lot of these
people and it's like these are just
imperfect people with many flaws and
sometimes they have good ideas on a few
issues but I want to hear from you about
that I want to hear from you about the
debate if you're watching on YouTube
please leave a response down below or
send me a tweet at D Pakman I do want to
hear from you make sure you're following
me on Twitter
we will take a quick break and be back
with all the day's news right after this